Oliver green arrow dig Spartan white
canary firestorm the atom heatwave
how did you get the name heatwave I
burned my family alive I like to light
things on fire
Oh things just got so much work you
really did it this time Barry y'all call
tech support
I had enough of this it's been an honor
know all of you to fight alongside now
it's up to you to keep our home safe
have fun storming the castle you gonna
use Princess Bride against me here we go
hey everybody happy 2017 best news ever
the CW renewed all of its TV shows so
all the superhero shows are coming back
I'll explain what's going on they air
like an epic promo reel so let's go
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything
oh my god this is so excited just to
clarify to the new Constantine animated
TV show was not the brand new show that
Geoff Johns was teasing that's going to
be something else so we'll talk about
that when they announce it so going down
the list so legends of tomorrow probably
going to double down on Legion of Doom
obviously the team is probably going to
change us a little bit the Legion of
Doom will probably cycle its roster to
probably some more black siren maybe
some more Justice Society characters in
Justice Society storylines from the
comics because vixen is on the team
citizen steel is on the team so I'm
expecting them to stay
heatwave we'll see about Sarah is
probably definitely going to stay on the
team Ray Palmer will probably stay on
the team but there's always like one or
two people that might get cycled in or
out the other new character that they
could introduce on legends of tomorrow
will be Constantine because they said
they would love to bring him back on
legends when the opportunity arises but
they're doing so many characters this
season there just wasn't an opportunity
for him so expect Constantine to come
back for the live action shows next
season maybe he'll even be a part of the
big four Knight crossover but the basic
way that they build the seasons will
stay the same like they'll still travel
around to different periods in time get
into all kinds of trouble while they're
chasing down the Legion of Doom so I
know the big question is is what about
the reverse-flash I would be willing to
bet that they're still going to be like
a big flash villain leading the Legion
of Doom
so hopefully that's the reverse-flash
just like looking forward to like
another big villain like Grodd or
someone crazy joining the Legion of Doom
as well so next on the list
Supergirl season 3 what they'll probably
do is still keep her earth in a
different universe so that they can do
Supergirl Superman stuff and they don't
have to get like really crazy with the
way they explain Superman on earth one
but here's the thing
Supergirl in the Legion of super-heroes
Mon L is a big legion character
Supergirl was a big legion character for
a little while but they haven't really
done a Legion of super-heroes storyline
yet they tease the Legion ring in the
fortress of solitude during Supergirl
season one but that's about all we've
gotten so far
so if you haven't read the comics the
Legion of super-heroes is from like the
very distant future and it's basically
like a giant team-up there's a version
of Brainiac on the team so I wouldn't be
surprised that they do some Brainiac
stuff but I'm also expecting Legion of
super-heroes
to at least make some sort of appearance
maybe during the big four night
crossover because they said they already
had the idea for like what the next big
four night crossover is going to be this
time they'll be a little more integrated
because this year there was really just
like the end tag they basically took
like a piece of the flash episode in
tacked it on to the end of the Supergirl
episode so expect more from the
Supergirl crossover later this year and
here's the thing too because the Justice
League movie is getting ready to drop at
the end of November this year when this
crossover would get ready to air like
this airs usually the beginning of
December so because they're happening
around the same time just expect like a
little bit of parody that doesn't mean
that they won't be able to use Superman
but just expects some more Superman
stuff to be happening I'm expecting him
back before the end of the season for
like a brief appearance but there's
still a lot of big rules about using
those big Justice League characters on
TV I would not be surprised if Wonder
Woman also gets teased on Supergirl too
like a version of Wonder Woman even if
they just make a reference to her or
just make some offhanded remark but if
there's any TV show that they're going
to tease Wonder Woman on it would have
to be Supergirl just because it's a
female lead show and she's also a
similar power level so it just makes
sense
next Big Show arrow season 6 so not a
huge surprise arrow pretty much has the
steam at this point to make it through
season 7 beyond season 7 really just
depends on what the ratings are and
whether or not the actors want to keep
making it because they just renewed
supernatural as well which is in like
it's 15 billion season so if they can
keep making that then obviously that's
like the benchmark for returning series
so as long as arrow is rated higher than
Supernatural they will continue to renew
arrow storyline though like what is
going to be the big arc for air
season six you know they still haven't
finished season five yet there's still
all this prometheus stuff that's
happening but like I said in my
Prometheus video he's tearing Oliver
down preparing him for a Green Arrow
rebirth like a rebirth in the comics so
season six of you know tentatively
calling
Green Arrow rebirth if you haven't read
that arc in the comics it's really just
like returning the character to his core
values Geoff Johns did a big rebirth for
pretty much every character in the DC
Universe in the comics it was great but
I know you're asking like what new big
characters from the comics are they
going to do during season six Marc
Guggenheim has said that they are
working up to the question he's like I
would love to do the question we've been
teasing Hub City which is where the
question comes from so obviously there's
always like a lot of new characters they
do from the comics they're doing Talia
al Ghul she'll probably come back in
season six but I'll also say the biggest
new character that we know right now
will probably be the question but
because of all the drama with the
Suicide Squad on TV do not be surprised
if they do some more Suicide Squad stuff
in season 6 just depending on how big it
gets that's like a Superman on Supergirl
situation too because there's a big
Suicide Squad movie franchise just don't
expect them to be able to do every
single character is they build into
season 6 season 7 also don't be
surprised if they do other spin-off word
the team ups like you know things that
are big enough that they could be their
own shows in their own right like birds
of prey that's something we haven't
quite got to on arrow yet Teen Titans
would be like another one or like a
live-action Young Justice situation just
more storylines that you feel like could
serve as the basis for a spin-off TV
show but number one of course the flash
season four nobody is surprised that it
got renewed it is literally the CW's
highest-rated show of course it's going
to get renewed they renew pretty much
like every single returning series with
a few exceptions what about the
storyline everyone's like who's going to
be like the new big villain is it going
to be another speedster is it going to
be a non speedster so what will happen
this season is that they'll wrap up
their savatage storyline in like all big
villains like the black flash at the end
of season 2 he'll probably just go off
and be sidelined for a little while so
they can come back for some big
adventure
in the future but the one big thing that
we definitely know they're going to do
is more flash family so we have new
speedsters Wally West and Jesse quick
and Jay Garrick Jay Garrick isn't really
that new he kind of started during
season two so they'll all come back they
could always decide to introduce a new
speedster beyond that like they'll
always be new speedsters on the show but
there are like core characters and then
there are characters that you only see
very briefly like the flash of earth 19
the accelerated man we don't really know
what his future on the show is because
they do so many different things each
season they go to different earths so in
keeping with that tradition
they'll also visit different earths of
the multiverse so we'll see more
different versions of the flash we might
see the daniel west reverse flash we
might see Thaddeus Thawne I think what
will definitely happen is the black
flash will make a brief appearance even
if it isn't part of a big art but like
the flash has been teasing this big
future war what they might decide to do
in a future season is a version of the
war of light only the light will just be
like the different colors of all the
speedsters lightning so you have like
evil reverse-flash family team-up versus
good flash family team-up because we do
have enough members of the flash family
that they could do like a big group
fight so I feel like that's mostly
building into defeating Savitt are at
the end of the season but in the future
you could just have like the good flash
family fighting a team up of evil
flashes so what I'm going to do next
week is I'm going to do like a flash
season for early predictions for
storylines and characters that they
could do so if you have any questions
about storylines or characters that you
want me to do bonus videos about just
let me know in the comments it's still
going to be a couple weeks before all
the shows come back they come back on
the 23rd so what's going to happen is
I'll still be doing the flash ring
giveaway make sure you turn alerts on so
you don't miss any of the videos there's
going to be all kinds of bonus videos
before that happens it's going to be
awesome and we have to talk about the
animated Constantine so if you guys
didn't know CW seed is like a different
streaming service that they have they've
been doing a vixen animated show it's a
bunch of episodes that are about five
minutes of peace they didn't say exactly
how many episodes of animated
Constantine there is going to be or how
long the episodes are going to be they
did say that Matt
is coming back to voice the character so
it will be the Constantine that you
remember but they didn't say whether or
not it's going to be a continuation of
the original Constantine series I'm
assuming not just because they can be as
crazy as they want so they'll be
continuity with the other CW series but
maybe not with the original Constantine
series so what's going to happen later
tonight is I'm going to do some more
comic book stuff then I'll post my
Sherlock video in the morning just up
you know minor schedule change so get
hype is going to be so awesome this year
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for the trailer for the
next episode of the flash you can click
here for the arrow trailer thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys in
the next video
you